hi [ __ ]
hi city i'm elon of early and
you were so much fun on this show i
loved getting to know you
congratulations you showed the world
who you are and what your style of drag
is you should be very proud of yourself
thank you i am i'm really happy with my
mother on the show i had so much fun
and watching everything back you know it
was nerve-wracking but it was great
this has been amazing as a non-binary
person to be able to come on the show
and be open about being who i am as a
two-spirit indigenous person
and i hope that my story and just me
being here and me being myself
can inspire and empower other people
like me you knew this elimination was
coming
for months now so how does how does it
feel now the
morning after we will say of it being
out into the world
you know i honestly haven't touched my
phone since last night i kind of
posted my last little drunk selfie with
priyanka and then i left my phone alone
i was like
we're going to deal with this maybe a
week but i'm very grateful obviously for
people
you know living and supporting and it's
it's special and i've read a couple
little things and i just put a smile on
my face
look we've seen with rupaul's drag race
that you don't
need to necessarily win to be a star
and i think you're a star i mean you're
a star now
thank you so much i really enjoyed all
the entrances that i was hooked
from the like 10 seconds i'm alona and
i'm a
i love anybody who can turn something
somewhat negative into a positive and
you've done that
with a judge's critique when i see that
booty and a little turnaround
a little full coverage foundation may
have helped you out a lot of people
were really really upset with what
jeffrey
had to say about your on the show
how do you feel now that you've watched
that back
and you've seen how people have reacted
to that online
you know it's been an experience because
for me in the moment i didn't really
take that very seriously
um like it didn't really affect me as
much as
i guess it does now you know seeing the
kind of twitterverse come together and
uh
really discuss this as a topic opened my
eyes because
people should be proud of everything
about themselves and like
to have a moment like that on a tv show
that so many young impressionable people
people are watching like it's
it's so i think you know at the end of
the day for me it's like we're all
people we're all learning
if anything now they know season two be
a little nicer maybe don't comment on
people's bodies necessarily as much i
think
2020 we're moving away from that now you
and scarlett have had
such a um roller coaster rock hide we
will say
of friendship
i'm not giving any negativity to you
like you're literally no you
i dropped something on the floor and
somehow you made me drop me something on
the floor about you
when you watch something like last
night's never ending
fight back do you just cringe no
i was laughing my ass off because the
thing about me and scarlet is we're like
real sisters and that's how our
friendship is we
fight all the time we make up right away
and it's like you know that's that's how
friends are like anyone that has like a
best friend can tell you that
good point um i want to talk to you
about bringing the awareness
of being too spirit to the show how
important has it been for you
and what kind of feedback have you
received from maybe other people who are
true spirit
it's really important to me because
growing up i never heard of the term
two spirits at all you know it took me a
while to actually like
just accept it and acknowledge and be
like okay yes like i'm
too severe like this is me like i see
myself so much in this
and uh just the feedback from the fans
and stuff like all of the messages just
like
make me cry like it's so heartwarming
like i knew
that this was gonna make a difference
and an impact i knew that
but when it's actually happening and
like
all these kids are messaging me it's
like
crazy knowing that there's all these
people that like went through so much in
their life without
you know anyone to look up to on a tv
screen because
that's my journey you know
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos